you got hit by a drunk driver you know
you were playing in the NFL and sure
enough I got diagnosed with leukemia
okay bring job I had my Dreamgirl
everything you got some light some death
threats oh yeah more than death dies I
mean you're gonna kill me in my family
why because we we spoke positive about
you you crossed you went way out of line
yeah but yeah that's supposed to be the
good person right yeah he says he's fine
telling me people like me should be dead
how could I do this to America how like
why like call me a terrorist never
started to highlight the KKK they have
functioning branches right now to this
day oh yeah and we don't take them as
like the epitome of Christianity in
America fierce Muslims and they
shouldn't yeah like why you're talking
about doing terrorists XY caused
somebody else a terrorist yeah there you
go that's a good point right some of the
people I went to their pages they said
that they bragged they go to church
twice a week every Sunday and Wednesday
but yet then they still have that heat
in their heart
yeah there's been more what they call
terrorist attacks from Christian
organizations than there ever has been
Muslim that's a statistical fact yeah
yeah he was making fun of me he follows
God you don't know why why I'd be around
them people following a lot uh-huh and
my somebody had explained to you no you
just said you don't follow God and you
were talking about God no fear for the
law you have no fear for what other
people think of you yeah what's gonna
stop that person from actually going out
and attacking somebody why because of
religious beliefs no for the Muslim
community how often do they deal with
this I'll I said words come there I said
so how do you feel now that you realize
it's not a bomb-making Factory
I mean I'm six before it I got people
literally threatening me over a
situation I said I want a cone greetings
a peace welcome to the D show thank you
for tuning in every week we are here hit
that notification bell so we can get you
the newest latest upcoming episodes
delivered directly to you my next guest
Tim former NFL player who got hit by a
drunk driver and then after that another
tragedy happened where he was given only
two years to live
so how you doing
actually I'm pretty good let's bring
them up to speed
whew it was about a couple months ago I
believe right oh yeah we hooked up and a
positive you on pretty much everything
we were seeing around us what I was
noticing and everything else yeah so we
talked a little bit about your former
days in the NFL yes bringing people up
to speed you got hit by a drunk driver
you know you were playing in the NFL and
that your life took a turn bring us up
to speed I'm right pretty much what
happened was I had a drunk driver taking
my career away from me finally I started
doing good I get myself right back on
the right path got my goals elevated
right till I needed them to and sure
enough I got diagnosed with lymphoma
leukemia okay did this happen after the
the drunk driver hits you about 16 years
later so so you were getting back into
the NFL no I was getting back into shape
though finally my legs started working
really good uh-huh I actually finally
started doing a lag I felt like I was
back to me again yeah I was finally able
to stop using my crutches I was finally
able to stop to get my life fully going
again yeah and then once everything else
again and now it seems like with my
healthy cane it's almost like all the
hard work I did just went back into
nothing almost but I'm not letting
affect me like that I'm letting it
affect me yes what can I do to overcome
this now how can I achieve this and how
can I still hit my goals mm-hmm now what
happened after paint the picture so
you're you're you get signed that was
your dream oh yeah NFL player oh yeah
pretty much everything was going great
for me I ended up I got my dream job I
had my dream girl everything and come to
find out that dreams ain't always what
they thought to be because whenever
everything happened I spent right around
five six months in the hospital got the
the woman I was with that I thought was
my one and only actually divorced me
while I was still going through the
rehabilitation in the hospital I ended
up meeting a great woman and
now have four beautiful children
and I can tell you this much right now I
now the it went from my fear of loss of
not being a play anymore to now my fear
of loss of how to get them taken care of
if anything shall go wrong mm-hmm now
what was this call it was called a
leukemia live for leukemia lymphoid
leukemia what is that for the pair for
leukemia is where your cells actually
start magnifying they thought I was
having a heart attack I went into the
hospital they did a cardiac catheter
they couldn't figure out why my heart
had the issues I had well then finally
they decided to do a PET scan and from
there they ended up finding out I had
the lymphoid leukemia at first we tried
pretty much everything I was kind of
nervous we did a lot of doctors
appointments a lot of everything and
it's it's one thing to go through it
luckily I had my wife's got through with
me but the scariest thing in the world
was having my kids see it so once I
actually got over that part right there
was able to actually get myself to I
helped me get myself to the point where
I know what I'm doing it and then I
remembered what I was working for in the
first place so now god forbids anything
does happen with me with this I'm
setting things up so my kids won't have
to worry about how they're gonna go to
school how they're gonna go ahead and
learn where they're gonna live and I'm
just gonna keep pushing forward on that
and what did they say they diagnosed it
as well they diagnosed says the lymph
we're looking at least a four so there's
really we actually tried the stuff we
did try there's not really much more to
do now I did meet a gentleman today that
I guess has a doctor that's doing a lot
with experimental as well as that I'm
gonna go try seeing him and I mean
hopefully that could do something what
did they say the sedate they actually
put a timeframe yeah on it what was the
time friend again I'm looking at a time
I was looking at around two years - how
long ago was that
about 13 14 months ago 13 14 months oh
yeah so that's that's coming up - where
where they told you two years it's yeah
I know that's six months
basically six to eight months yeah and
then on top of that I came can I go
ahead and talk about what happened after
your shows well yeah so we bring you we
didn't go into the details it was really
short and I heard about your situation
and I'm really
to meet you and we met and then we
started to talk on some really positive
things most positive I mean the
Brotherhood I got to see it that I've
seen III go to church Salem Baptist in
Decatur yeah let's see for the people
who didn't get to see that clip I was I
was asking you because we were at a
convention and it was a lot of Muslims
around yeah I was just asking you how
was your interaction been with the
Muslims and yeah I got to realize you
were talking positive yes nothing but
positive the Brotherhood do they have
the unity that they have it's it's
unstoppable I mean that like literally
we're normally and then if that wasn't
bad enough I literally got to see them
go outside there was some homeless
people outside as you remember outside
the convention they brought them in they
gave them clothes they gave them food
name one other event will you ever see
that I go to events on a monthly basis
and I'm not gonna lie I've never seen
nothing like that before yeah I mean
I've seen people give the homeless
couple bucks from the walking in out of
either actually actual good guy or guilt
but they never actually just take them
in get them clothes make sure taken care
of they even gave them a couple what
were them things they gave him some
coffee and there was an organization
there that actually puts people through
college onto ships yes and they actually
took them in now and they had FIGS
and they had coffee and they were
literally giving these guys coffee
making sure they were warm and everybody
some dates dates is what it was yes and
yeah they made sure these guys had food
in their belly and they made sure they
had clothes on them they even were
asking well where are you going this Ned
make sure they had a place to go over
their head yeah I mean that was amazing
you don't see that nowhere and because
of that if I'm if correct me if I'm
wrong you got some some death threats oh
yeah more than death threats of you
actually so this is this is in response
to the video we have will leave the
video in the description you can
actually see what we were talking about
and then you were bringing me up you
need what was very short and surprised
though blew my mind is there's people
making comments on that at first the
comments started off calling me a
terrorist and stuff and I mean two of
the comments were right there literally
like an extension where I put a like on
the thing and then made a comment well I
put positivity or something like that
nothing negative at all
I got called a terrorist I mean I don't
understand what makes it a terrorist
I mean that's when they're getting wrong
was the concept between rheology
religion and reality I mean I didn't see
a single terrorist there there was no
terrorist actions and then it started
off and all I did is defended the fact
of the like what I seen versus what he
was stating yeah I mean it led into a
thing as you don't where it became more
of it led into more of how do I put this
a situation where it wasn't just him and
I started wondering you know for the
Muslim community how often do they deal
with this I'll I said was what five
minutes of positivity and I've gotten a
month's worth of hate I mean what-what I
went to pretty much an event of love
that's what it was it was prayer it was
education and it was just the community
finding ways to work the Muslim
community find ways to work together and
grow and next thing I know I'm a bad
person for it and there's no way I mean
I help out with Bill Chicago I mean I
see the next thing you know they're
gonna start saying like I mean I don't
even know how to put into words you
actually got a yeah you you got to
someone found your phone number yeah I
had my phone number attached initially
to one of my accounts and I guess he
just started googling me and googling me
well I get a phone call and I'm sitting
there with my wife and kids and I
literally had to leave the room from the
situation because I mean this guy's
literally I mean he's telling me people
like me should be dead how could I do
this to America I like why like call me
a terrorist and everything you know I
call it stupid I tried to rationalize
with somebody I don't know over the
phone another common thing with you but
you hang up so many times you finally
answer I'm not gonna sit there and call
the cops and hide behind the cops I'm
gonna try explaining to this guy listen
here you're making a mistake why would
you judge people like that why would you
go ahead so now you're trying to reason
you turn to reason with them yeah hoping
that some good will come out yeah and
then they turned into a situation where
he literally tagged me with a whole
bunch more people on Facebook and pretty
much put some like it just turned into
some bigger a bigger
bigger Wow and all it was was positivity
I mean even you even you the video thing
we had you put on their love I mean at
no point do we like we wasn't talk about
doing anything negative and any means
possible I mean anybody that follows me
knows I deal with sixteen different
charitable organizations sixteen
including one of them does nothing but
get gang members out of gangs and off
the streets if that's terrorism what's
Americanism yeah I mean III do what I
have to do to help my family I want to
show my kids that you don't have to be
scared of anything that you don't just
cuz you hear something's bad find it
like find out I mean it ain't like if
it's something that's legal to be there
obviously there's a reason why it's not
banned mm-hmm and the way I look at the
situation at no point did I see any
negative behalf of anything they had
going there and honestly and that's one
of the reasons why the company I work
with now that's why I like them so much
because I did the same thing is what we
were talking about what they I mean you
ain't does the same thing that that you
see them out there they set up they
educate with what the programs they got
going with the Quran and all that what
other what other companies brings
together with a family like that yeah
just like you guys do I'm trying to the
way you guys were out there with the
books and stuff they had that other
group of people that was right there by
you yeah they'd send it to the
correctional centers and stuff uh-huh
again peace came peace yeah never other
organizations to do that mm-hmm I mean
don't get me wrong it's that's not a bad
thing
you're giving people that said that that
feel like they have no hope
motivation to succeed yeah motivation to
do positivity motivation to learn the
motivation to grow if that's terrorism
who ever got sentimental idealism of it
is all wrong mm-hmm you got a chance to
kind of experience a little bit what
many Muslims go through and now imagine
someone like a let's say a Muslim woman
who was imitating the mother of Jesus
Mary Mary she wears the that was called
a hijab now you know that she's a Muslim
and now you can now imagine the
not only threats but physical assaults
that have happened to these I believe
100% yeah I mean I'm six foot four I got
people literally threatening me over a
situation I can't imagine I don't mean
this the stereotype or anything else but
I was about a good two foot taller than
almost everybody I've seen out there
yeah and I'm not I'm not as peaceful as
first mmm-hmm
I speak my mind very easily and there's
a lot of guys there even if they get
offended they they excuse themselves
from the situation
yeah so that I can't imagine what
they're doing yeah I can't imagine the
way that they get disrespected I mean I
did something positive for five minutes
you know like a blink of the eye and I
got threatened like that imagine people
that have that that where the ropes it
goes it they see it on the way to church
yeah I mean imagine the way they're
treated why do you think this is fear
fear so many people is something the
government originally 9/11 everything
else it was like install fear into
people mm-hmm
it was so many people think
automatically they see somebody a four
that's foreign and they automatically
assume terrorist yeah I mean obviously
that's the only way I could think I
never thought like that yeah
some of us can can't imagine it but yeah
I met a pastor he was I was visiting
Colorado and I just got done speaking
and I noticed him and I approached him
and we spoke and while we were speaking
and then he had obviously got to ask his
questions he had some some questions and
that's the first that making that human
connection and doing what he did he was
brave enough to come in but in one point
in the conversation I heard him
sincerely say that he was actually
scared to come there and I said so how
do you feel now that you realize it's
not a bomb-making factory and how do you
feel like being around Muslims making
that connection with other human beings
that was that first step and he was very
happy he was elated he was feeling much
more at ease and education was the
second step so obviously making that
first connection with with the Muslims
visiting a mosque connecting and then
getting yourself educated I think that's
that's another key to eliminate some of
these I call them false fear
manufactured fear that's been created
I agree I mean only that look online
yeah look at the look online about like
I mean and this is one thing I said a
little bit of it whenever I was on the
show I mean I like I said before that
everybody it's a misjudgment if you look
at the situation's the way they are
versus the way that people are
programmed to perceive them you actually
realize I mean if you go to Ireland it's
a I'm pretty sure the Catholics and the
Protestants yes I don't rule it war with
each other you go to Greece it's not
even a religion issue it's it's a lot of
the Greeks versus the Turkish and it's
like that in all parts of the world not
just one part not just two but they try
to they try to push away from it they
try to help each other girl from it
they're trying to fix the boundaries
here it's like everybody's trying to
install them worse yeah I mean once
taking you guys somebody sitting there I
mean look even in the comments on I'm
just like a basic thing
it starts off somebody says some
positive or puts like a little cute
video up so the next thing you know you
got people making comments and then
either becomes a race or religion thing
yeah and then from there just becomes
hate all the way down yeah it just blows
my mind I mean we did a message of peace
I mean she's agreed Ian says you caught
it yeah and honestly it was very
positive I mean I went home and I even
showed the members of my church I was
like listen I had a great time you know
great people and then next thing you
know I just start getting the messages I
started getting comments I mean right
there directly on a page where people
have a right to post our own opinion I
understand that that's their opinion
that's their thoughts but there's a
difference between an opinion and a hate
crime and some of the comments does
being made on there there was one
gentleman that made a comment on there
that he did not appreciate it he was
he's been Muslim his whole life he's
never done any violent actions he has no
criminal record and then they like it
was almost like he was targeted for a
second even yeah it's like why what did
he do to deserve that mm-hmm
realistically he did nothing that I mean
that those type of people if you look at
they have more in common with that
fringe element that the media usually
highlights and tries to represent
represent them as if they're you know
the majority of Muslims like let's say
someone does an extreme act
out there and has nothing to do with
Islam and if you look at all the data
you have more of a chance people make
this example experts in this area of
collecting data on terrorism and whatnot
you actually have more of a chance of
getting hit by your furniture or getting
killed by your furniture than some kind
of Islamic terrorists out there right
but these people out here who are
spreading this kind of hate and misery
who are who are who have been misled to
believe many of these false things but
it's it's one thing being misled to
believe something that's false but then
you can either continue to stay ignorant
or you get educated exactly that's the
thing and the scary thing is many of
these people who are attacking attacking
you and people like you who are speaking
the truth they're actually choosing to
stay ignorant when the worst thing of it
is is some of them saying people were
people that were following me right
before talking about how much they love
the positivity that the positive stuff I
was doing yeah but then I was sending
the anger the grief and all the mental
anguish came out and then it started
making me wonder is like why you're
talking about doing terrorist acts by
calling somebody else a terrorist yeah
there you go that's a good point right
yeah I mean you're gonna kill me in my
family why because we spoke positive
about you frost you crossed that you
went way out of line yeah but yeah
that's supposed to be the good person
right yeah he says he's free to actually
threaten you and your family yeah yeah I
mean one of them like literally if you
go to the initial video you're gonna see
where it actually starts where it leads
into it and the thing that blows my mind
is that means he actually follows it so
why are you following something you hate
so much mm-hmm that's interesting yeah I
wonder why you go out of your way the
way I look at it is if you if you hate
something that much leave it alone
yeah avoid it go somewhere else I mean
there's been people in my life I didn't
like and if I see them I just don't talk
to them and I walk the other direction
yeah I mean why threaten people I mean
the difference of it is and I don't even
really thought it as a threat I fill in
as sincerity from them because if you
have that much hate in your heart you're
gonna sit there and publicly say it that
means you have no fear for the law you
have no fear for what other people think
of you yeah what's going to stop that
person from actually going out and
attacking somebody why because of
religious beliefs yeah so this over also
there was a
a lot of people who had seen that video
huh oh yeah yeah was there some positive
feedback out loud yes actually my not oh
this is a part that a lot of the Muslim
communities and stuff that actually
noticed they came up they told me thank
you so much
actually my church even liked it a lot
of the guys from my church came up and
told me hey guess what hey you did a
great job did you have fun they look
like nice people yeah and I kept
tournaments it wasn't the people it was
the the it was the place it was
everything yeah and honestly I mean I
met a lot of positive people I've made a
lot of friends actually at the event mhm
and I can tell you this much right now
when people want to sit there and not
say this right here I'll say it right
like this right here even for those who
want to sit there and say like call them
names threaten people for the religious
beliefs especially the Muslim community
that's doing nothing wrong to you think
about it I want you to go home I want
you to look yourself in the mirror and
ask yourself the two true question who
is the terrorist at that point you're
gonna cause harm to a family and to a
culture of people because you don't
understand them if anything is terrorism
that's terrorism the breakdown the
mental abuse I feel sorry for the
children I seen the way the children
were dressed and everything else there
and with if somebody's wanted to come at
me a grown man today what are they gonna
say to a kid mm-hmm we're thinking I
mean I mean I I see I got to see the
looks I was actually with one of my
colleagues that I work with and we went
to Brazilian steakhouse and while we're
sitting there we seen a group of Muslim
kids come in with their family and
everything else in like I never noticed
it I never paid attention before maybe
it's because of the situation I'm
dealing with but you can actually watch
the way people look at them and move
away from them and make comments with
them standing right there no fear no no
no restrictions on what they get what
they would say so I mean if you think
about the situation what everybody needs
to do is stop looking at it like that
talk to somebody you see a guy that you
fear walk up to him shake his hand it
doesn't matter what religion he is he'll
talk to you yesterday he'll be real with
you I mean the the simplistic okay
it's a belief issue but at the same
point they would they wanted well the
big biggest response I got well I'm a
I'm a true Christian no because if
Christians started acting like
Christians there would be no need for
Christianity I know that sounds weird
but the love I mean where's the love
religious religion is supposed to be
love it's supposed to be knowing that
there's something up there knowing that
hey I want to go to heaven whatever you
call it whatever you want it to be I
don't care what religion you are it's to
do good and as like it asks for
forgiveness for the wrongs you've done
and move forward now how can you do that
sit there and say you're doing that when
you sit there and I guarantee it
some of the people I went to their pages
they said that they bragged they go to
church twice a week every Sunday and
Wednesday but yet then they still have
that heat in their heart yeah I can't
understand that part because one of the
greatest Commandments is to love your
neighbor like you love yourself right
exactly so after loving God loving your
neighbor and we're not going anywhere
I mean Muslims are here to stay
Christians are here to stay we all have
to learn to get along we all have to
learn to you know cooperating goodness
right and and I like what what you're
saying is that and this is important for
everybody because if the the majority if
the the majority of good people remain
silent then the minority of evil people
out there they're gonna start to reign
havoc so many people they don't agree
with a lot of these things but they stay
silent
well you're courageous enough to step up
and speak up many people they're staying
while the people are staying silent and
that's how that silent these this
minority that's out there spreading this
hate they're gonna end up having a
bigger and bigger platform and you're
gonna think they're the majority oh
that's in there I mean do they realize
how many religions are out there I mean
they're focusing on one religion I mean
there's so many religions I mean you got
Muslim yeah Israelites got Christians
you got Catholics you got Baptists you
got I can go on for days yeah and then
you go into other countries I mean they
got one whole religious structure that's
separated even
in Kenya in Nigeria yeah we had one
thing that got in common is everywhere
you go there's still Christians there
and there's still Muslim sir
this issues not as big as in other
countries I mean it's still there it's
still there but the hate part of it yeah
you gave some good examples also I think
you mentioned we talked a little bit
about for example if people started to
highlight the KKK
they have functioning branches right now
to this day oh yeah and we don't take
them as like the epitome of Christianity
or the drug cartels exactly they're
crossed up they got the cross you know
they're practicing cell saver cracking
Christians but imagine the media took
them as if they represent mainstream
Christianity exactly yeah just like this
right here is one thing another thing
I'm like whatever you watch shows it's
there anymore so many shows actually
stereotype to the point where it's like
literally I mean you you watch the show
you see a Muslim in you don't see a
Muslim in you see a Muslim stereotype
you said there you see a Christian man
you don't see a Christian man you see a
holier-than-thou Christian man letici on
there but in reality a lot of them same
things show the feud think it's it's
it's creating the same thing for the
kids that's gonna grow up that's gonna
create the same thing for the kids it's
time we just show love this is uh this
is this is one of the things that that
usually like when I spoke to the the
pastor and Colorado David when we focus
on many of these commonalities that we
have together you know the people will
be amazed like and and this is why
education is so key many people you know
just by defining certain words like for
instance Muslim is simply one who has
submitted to the will of God just like
Jesus submitted to the will of God Moses
Abraham and Islam is to do that action
of submitting one's will to God
Christians don't know that there's a
whole chapter in the Quran named after
Jesus's Blessed Mother Mary it's in the
Koran a whole chapter a Muslim can by
himself or herself a ticket to the
Hellfire if they deny Jesus as one of
the mightiest messengers ever sent to
mankind with that same message that all
the other prophets came worship the
Creator not the creation so we have a
deep reverence and love
only for his mother but for Jesus
himself you cannot utter one word of
disrespect about Jesus so I think this
is like heart touching and softening
when you hear these things you know what
many people don't know these
commonalities well the funny thing
talking about that right there I'm not I
try to be the best Christian I can't be
and I'm not gonna lie I had a situation
happen I think it was two days ago we
were we were actually in Chicago and I
ran into a gentleman at one of the
events we were at yeah and I said I used
Jesus's name and to come and I mean you
guys are good he actually corrected me
and asked me not to use the Lord's name
Jesus's name like that because that's
disrespectful
and I was like this right here I was
like he actually went into detail to
explain to me that just all the names
out there like that is a form of
blasphemy it's a form of disrespect
because you're saying that something how
did he put it I wish I could put it the
way he did he said it sews was this some
Christian or Muslim that was a Muslim
gentleman Muslim oh we usually say peace
be upon him yeah but you know I don't
know I told him I compared I was like I
said some like I think Jesus Christ I
said something like Jesus Christ he was
not like I complimented his outfit yeah
and he corrected me and he said no
you're not supposed to say that and I
thought at first because as I my first
response to this because of lack of
knowledge
I said oh yeah I forgot you guys don't
you guys and my first words to him and
I'm not gonna like oh you guys I believe
in Jesus he corrected me he's like no
taint that we don't believe in Jesus
this is the Muslim now yes okay what'd
he say he actually went into detail
talking about how he looked Jesus was a
prophet just and start going into that
moment everything else and explained to
me no matter how you look at it to use
their names in vain especially to
convert vain he was like he went into
detail the word vain isn't like the same
thing I was doing then I complimented
him on his clothing to be over excited
about some of these appearances to be
vain so like he went into this long
detailed thing about like literally
gamey collection not to use Jesus's name
like that to be respectful towards Jesus
yeah pretty much
and that and that goes what I'm saying
that you know if many Christians if they
knew they sit in and and and talk with
the Muslims and really know our
viewpoint obviously obviously we get the
elephant out of the room and this is
with all due respect we don't believe he
was a literal God or son of God but he
called people to worship God okay we got
that out of the room fine let's do that
but let's go on on the on these other
things how he greeted people he would
say a shallow lake Salam alaikum the way
he prayed the same way Muslims prayed he
fell on his face and prayed to God he
didn't eat pork he was chased moral he
was thats a moral message all those
commonalities right are there with us
and we like the gentleman the brother
who was telling you he we take strong
offense if someone disrespects Mohammed
or Jesus they're all brothers of one
another who they all came with the same
message worship the one God the Creator
not the crazy we respect them all of
them you know deny one deny him off
that's how it is yeah it caught me off
guard because I literally I was educated
yeah he didn't get mad at me he didn't
getting he didn't threaten my family he
didn't sit there and act like an idiot
oh yeah she was very positive yeah yeah
I mean after we got done and everything
even got his business card never yeah
and here's one thing I like to because a
lot of times you know look you'll be a
football fan right what's your favorite
team my favorite team yeah Bears you
like the Bears you'd probably like for
your friend to like the Bears two more
than the Packers or something right
right even you can be you know let's say
you drive a certain car you know you you
you believe that Ford is the way to go
the other one wants to Toyota but then
your friend your friend says look he
says found on the road dead you know
that's it okay so he's like Commission
advisory vote daily so now is he a
traitor now because he's trying to get
you to go with with let's say the Toyota
that you have less problems or you're
trying to get him to go with this team I
mean what I'm trying to make the
comparison is like when you when you go
and eat Italian food there you go and
you pick for this team or that obviously
this way of life you know the way of
life that you choose to live by that is
connected to God is more serious right
but I mean that's all you should feel
it's not like someone's trying to let's
say push something on you they're
sharing their educating this like we are
we're educating people on this way of
life if you like what we have to say you
accept if you don't reject but doesn't
mean we can we can't still you know be
friends and you know work together on
on other important issues and that are
out there affecting the world are that
we live in well it's kind of like this
right here I got to see the restraint
and I even asked him why afterwards we
just actually did an event one of my
friends Abraham he was he got
disrespected horribly yeah and Booth is
one of my friends Abraham Muslim guy yes
yeah and long story short like why you
get disrespected for originally it was
it was over a disagreement over the
event but it became into something more
like hate hate words started coming out
yeah and the way he handled the
situation
I honestly to say I've never seen
anybody you know like that like I know I
wouldn't have handled I actually stepped
up here to tell me please step down
[Laughter]
crutches and all that yeah I mean I was
about to lose my temper yeah and the bad
thing is the people that was with me I
mean we all almost lost our Kippur in
here and I literally asked us hey can
you guys please just calm down going
down yeah and he stood there and was
literally for about 15 minutes he sat
there and he tried to reason with the
gentleman after he was pretty much
called racist names
he was like made fun of right there and
he stood his ground
he stayed positive who was calling him
racist names another gentleman that was
actually one of the gentlemen that we
were actually using to put on the vent
through yeah and like he actually I
don't know how he did it but he
maintained his common his calmness and
everything else and after after we after
we got done with the situation we're
getting ready to leave me and my brother
actually wouldn't even talk to him or
like why didn't why don't you just lose
it like we had your back I mean yeah and
I'm not trying to promote violence or
anything but if you would have heard the
stuff that was said I mean I had my
blood boiling yeah
and that's she always was gonna say
something when you got a good man that
sits there and helps people when he gets
disrespected those around them I figured
you know maybe he's just all about peace
I'll stick up for him but his exact
words was what would that solve you
can't be ignorant with a stick is what
he told me that's powerful look at that
yeah you can't be a chance to beat
ignorance with a stick and I was like
well these definitely are more like lugs
wouldn't solve anything then the guy
would have a reason to sit there and say
why he did what he did yeah
and how he feels like he feels so I said
there so I I see the way that the
community gets treated in a hole now and
I don't like it it's not right I mean
the way I look at it is is you don't see
the Muslims going up there and calling
the Christians terrorists but yet if you
look overall
over time there's men and this is what I
mean it goes literally to a better
Church there's been more what they call
terrorist attacks from Christian
organizations than there ever has been
Muslim that's a statistical fact yeah
yeah and yet you don't you don't see the
Muslims going up to the Christian
churches saying that you still see them
saying love ya ain't only now right
there if you watch even the way you come
up and when I go up to shake somebody's
hand I was always taught coming up and I
don't like this right if you notice they
go like this right here they comfort
them they like coming peacefully to even
show they mean it's you feel peace
whatever year the hand signal we start
with peace we said yes I'm aleikum peace
be with you
yeah yeah and I've heard so much
ridiculous stuff like that's what when
and one of my friends actually corrected
the guy there and the guy felt like an
idiot just walked off but I had one
gentleman literally I guess he's seen
videos of me being on your last show
yeah and he was making fun of me he
follows God you don't know why why I'd
be around them people following a lot
uh-huh and my somebody had explained to
you no you just said you don't follow
God and you were talking about God yeah
so I mean he got a little bit of a treat
of reality right there with themselves
and I found a humorous like I mean the
gut you know you told somebody something
that they realized that they were wrong
when the only thing they could do is
walk away yeah but seriously I mean on
the biggest note of the situation I mean
what's wrong with people today mm-hmm
what happened like I know they say in
the 1950s anymore I know it's not the
1960s anymore I know it's definitely not
the 1920s anymore but what when did it
become okay to walk up and just racially
attack somebody
to attack from a spiritual meeting to
attack somebody's mental being and then
we sit here and like the biggest thing
everybody wants to focus on is
anti-bullying yeah oh my God look at the
bullying in the school and then you
teach your kid to walk up to them and
sit there and make fun of them yeah
so what why should your kid not be
picked on but your kid can walk up and
start making racist slurs at a grown man
so you're trying to you're it's
contradictory it's hypocrisy not yeah
yeah like everything I mean when I was a
kid
believe it or not the area we grew up in
there was no hate back and forth no
matter what religion you were no matter
what your mindset was you know what your
cool people you got love if you're not
don't be around us in nowadays ever
since all this stuff it's like and I'm
not even say just Illinois but America
fierce Muslims and they shouldn't yeah I
mean I'm not saying that you you that
there's not certain Muslims you should
be scared there's not certain Christians
you should be scared but it's not the
fact that they're Muslim that used to be
scared of them it's the people it's not
the religion I actually say if a Muslim
is falling the more he's following Islam
the more you have less to actually fear
him all right but I think most people a
lot of times this hate is perpetuated
and people are socially conditioned
according to the culture you got a lot
of you just the kind of things people
are seeing all day and all night on the
TV and you know the the movies and the
rappers and all these other things that
are out there conditioning the mind and
whatnot so these people are affected you
know by their social environment but
Islam is actually calling people away
from these things that our mind and
heart corrupters and you mentioned it's
interesting that's why education is so
important when you mentioned the guy
said oh I wish of God they worship Allah
right but that just you know when you
know the simple facts on this using
Christians who are actually Arabic
speaking their Arabic speaking
Christians they have an Arab a Bible in
Arabic in that first chapter of Genesis
alone the word Allah is used because God
the word God didn't come into existence
until what
like around 1600s exactly and Jesus
would say Aloha and Aramaic he spoke
Aramaic he would say Aloha
he didn't say God all right and it's
closer to Allah ello I love him Allah so
this is the same this is just Semitic
languages so you can see how far people
are away from reality and and how how
compounded on compounded ignorance on
top of ignorance and then you get some
more FoxNews and then that adds today to
the problem but before before we cut out
again I commend you you know some people
like you who've made the human
connection who've connected with your
brothers and sisters because we're all
you know in this world together right
we're all we say brothers and sisters in
humanity because we all have the same
father Adam then there's brothers and
sisters and family and there's brothers
and sisters in faith but in brothers as
brothers and sisters in humanity we want
to see violence go down we want to see
poverty you know be eradicated we want
our children to succeed our families to
grow we want the good things so those
are the kind of good things that we want
to work together on this hate is gonna
just hinder all that right and I destroy
it and I would like to say something too
I would like to say this right here for
those who said they're okay I understand
it's the same situation that we've been
dealing with with the last few hundred
years with black and white yeah yeah the
only difference of it is is now it's
Christian Muslim mm-hmm and the bad
thing of it is is let the hate go let
the racism go that's pretty much what it
is you guys want to sit down you say you
want anti-bullying then stop and didn't
stop bullying I mean if you look at the
majority of the people that's out there
that's having these issues the same
people give it to somebody else you
can't sit there and yell at your child
from pulling a girl's hair and then go
ahead and see somebody and pull your
kids across the street because oh my god
she has what is that real cold on the
job a job yes right yeah okay just like
Mary Rose yes yes just like Mary I mean
if mother Mary was walking down the road
would you go ahead and grab your kids
and go to the South Street or like a nun
or even this much right now like watch
like if
whatever church you go to whatever
religion you have if you senior pastor
father or whatever walking towards you
are you gonna go to the other side of
the road No
so stop doing it grow up we're all
brothers and sisters one way or no no
matter what religion you have I mean
respect your neighbors respect your
neighbors yeah I mean it is at the same
point you don't have to have the same
belief to have this you got the same
heart you had the same blood and I don't
I don't care what color you are you go
outside in the Sun long enough you're
gonna get sunburned you go ahead and you
cut yourself with a knife I'm sorry to
be the one to tell you this you're still
gonna bleed so until you find a way to
fix all that stuff and change all that
stuff remember you guys are the same
everybody's the same
stop the hate show love I mean III heard
it I heard a good phrase just yesterday
I know we're wrapping up but there's
there's actually a boxing gym here in
town that got its put down the guns pick
up the gloves this one same thing but
instead of picking up the gloves or
picking it up the guns they should just
pick up a book get educated learn get
educated Washington watch the D show
watch the Dean show the exactly don't
come back with hate on the Dean show
there you go I really i will debate you
thank you very much for being with us
almost if you're actually doing also
you're doing a lot of motion
motivational speaking nowadays oh yeah
if someone wanted to get in contact with
you you know are you accepting
invitation oh oh yeah they can either
contact you am i they can go online get
a hold of you a.m. or they can go ahead
and on Instagram it's Timmy the Greek
one P I M my th e gr ee k number one
there you go but the easiest way get
ahold of you am alright thank you guys
for tuning in and you can go ahead and
subscribe hit the notification bell and
leave the gems that you picked up from
here in the comments want to hear some
more positivity things that you walked
away with some of maybe some advice that
you'd like to give for people to be able
to grow more from this show and maybe
some things that you picked up on share
your experiences and we'll see you next
time here on the D show God willing
until then peace be with you so I'll
make